WHO'S ON HERE? WE NEED AN
AUTHOR, THOUGH. HEY, YOU'RE ONE
OF THE AUTHORS. SHOULD I JUST DO
IT? YEAH. ALL RIGHT, LET ME
LET'S LET'S START THIS UP. CALL
THE Â C¯ AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. WE
WILL PASS THE GAVEL TO THE VICE
CHAIR. AND THEN I COULD PRESENT
SENATOR DAHLE HERE. YOU MAY
PROCEED, MR. JOYCE Dð HERE.
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH. ALL RIGHT.
FINE. ALL RIGHT. OKAY, LET'S DO
IT. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE. AND IT'S AN
HONOR TO PRESENT FROM THE DAIS.
SO, SB 1143, OBVIOUSLY, WE WERE
WORKING ON ON IT RELATING TO,
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE. THE
BILL IS REALLY FOCUSING IN ON
PAINTCARE NOW, AND WE WILL BE
WORKING FURTHER ON THE BROADER
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE ISSUES
NEXT YEAR. BUT AS IT. YEAH, JUST
PAUSE FOR A SECOND. WE COULD GET
A ROLL CALL, ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SENATORS ALLEN ARE HERE. ALLEN
HERE. DALLY HERE. DALLY HERE.
GONZALEZ HERE. GONZALEZ. HERE.
HURTADO MENGIBAR. NGUYEN HERE.
NGUYEN HERE. SKINNER. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. YOU MAY
PROCEED. ALL RIGHT, SO, THIS
BILL WOULD EXPAND THE STATE'S
EXISTING SUCCESSFUL PAINT
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM TO ALL PAINT
AND PAINT RELATED PRODUCTS, IF
PROPERLY MANAGED. UNUSED PAINT
AND SIMILAR PAINT RELATED
PRODUCTS CAN BE HAZARDOUS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH IN THE ENVIRONMENT,
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS A
SUCCESSFUL PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM FOR
PAINT. AS I, AS MOST FOLKS HERE
KNOW, IT'S CALLED PAINT CARE, IT
MANAGES LEFTOVER ARCHITECTURAL
PAINT THROUGH EDUCATION AND
CONVENIENT COLLECTION LOCATIONS.
ONCE COLLECTED, LEFTOVER PAINT
CAN LARGELY BE DIVERTED FROM
LANDFILLS, CAN BE REUSED.
RECYCLED, NOW, AEROSOL COATINGS
WERE ADDED TO THE PROGRAM JUST
LAST YEAR, BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN
RELATED PRODUCTS SUCH AS
AUTOMOTIVE, REFINISH, PAINT,
MARINE AND ANTI-FOULING PAINTS
SURFACE ADHESIVES THAT ARE STILL
NOT INCLUDED AS OF TODAY. NOW,
CALRECYCLE WILL ALREADY BE
REVISING THEIR REGULATIONS FOR
THE PROGRAM DUE TO THE ADDITION
OF AEROSOLS, AND THERE'S BROAD
INDUSTRY SUPPORT FOR INCLUDING
THESE OTHER RELATED PRODUCTS
UNDER ONE PROGRAM TO IMPROVE
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE
MANUFACTURERS. SO THIS BILL WILL
EXPAND PAINT CARE TO ALL THE
REMAINING PAINT AND PAINT
RELATED PRODUCTS, ALIGN THE
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINES FOR THE
NEWLY ADDED PRODUCT CATEGORIES
TO CREATE CONSISTENCY. THE
EXPANSION WILL HELP PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT FROM IMPROPERLY
DISPOSED OF MATERIAL, IMPROVE
CONVENIENCE FOR CONSUMERS.
REDUCE FINANCIAL AND LOGISTICAL
BURDENS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BY
MANAGING PAINT AND ALLIED
PRODUCTS IN A SINGLE PROGRAM,
AND IT'S WITH ALL OF THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES? I
THINK WE DO. JORDAN, FROM OUR
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL.
YEAH. JORDAN. WELCOME BACK. THE
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL IS A PROUD SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORTER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, LAUREN
VALENCIA, REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN COATINGS ASSOCIATION,
WHO IS THE TRADE ASSOCIATION OF
PAINT AND COATINGS MANUFACTURERS
WHO CREATED PAINT CARE. VERY
EXCITED FOR THIS EXPANSION AND
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE, DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION HERE TODAY? ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF. 1140. 1143. SEEING NONE, WE
WILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT. BRING
IT BACK FOR A. RESPECTFUL VOTE.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE FOLKS ON
THE INDUSTRY SIDE AND THE AND
THE PAINT CARE WHO WORKED WITH
US ON THIS AND OF COURSE OUR
INCREDIBLE STAFF. ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. THANK YOU. HAVE A MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OKAY SB
1143. THE MOTION IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN SENATORS ALLEN I, ALLEN I
DALLI. DALLI AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE HURTADO. MENGIBAR.
NGUYEN NO. WIN. NO. SKINNER. 3
TO 1. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL HOLD THE
ROLL OPEN FOR THAT SEN. NEWMAN,
YOU MAY APPROACH THE BENCH, I
JUST WANT TO SAY, SENATOR DOLLY
SO BELIEVES IN GOVERNMENT
INCREASING GOVERNMENT
EFFICIENCY. THAT HE HAD ME
PRESENT THE BILL FROM HERE SO AS
NOT TO HAVE TO. YEAH, I KNOW IT
WAS FOR ME, TOO, BUT THIS IS THE
NEW. I THOUGHT IT WAS LIKE WHEN
YOU GO INTO YOUR HOME AND YOUR
PARENTS ARE FIGHTING AND YOU
THINK MAYBE YOU SHOULDN'T GO IN.
WELL, THANKFULLY THAT WAS A WE
WERE ALL, THE CHAIR AND THE VICE
CHAIR WERE IN AGREEMENT. SO,
LET'S NOW HEAR FROM YOU, SENATOR
NEWMAN, WHO IS HERE TO PRESENT
SB 707. ALL RIGHT. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THE
AMENDED VERSION OF SB 707, WHICH
WILL ESTABLISH A FIRST IN THE
NATION EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA FOR CLOTHING AND
HOUSEHOLD TEXTILES. WE TOOK
MULTIPLE ROUNDS OF AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY AS A RESULT OF A
VERY DELIBERATE, INTENSIVE,
CONSULTATIVE, TWO YEAR
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
AND ALONG THE WAY ALSO
INCORPORATED TECHNICAL FEEDBACK
FROM CALRECYCLE, RECENT
AMENDMENTS ADDRESSED THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF ONLINE
MARKETPLACES WHILE ALSO MAKING
VARIOUS TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
CHANGES ON THE BASIS OF THESE
AMENDMENTS. WE'VE REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, THE AMERICAN APPAREL
AND FOOTWEAR ASSOCIATION MOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION. THIS BILL NOW
HAS OVER 150 ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT, INCLUDING WELL-KNOWN
BRANDS LIKE H&M AND IKEA, AND NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. YES, SIR. THANK YOU,
MISTER CHAIR. MEMBERS JASON
SCHMELTZER HERE ON BEHALF OF
CPSC, SPONSOR OF THE BILL. ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA
STOPWASTE WESTERN PLACER WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY AND SWANA,
ALL IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. JUST
WANT TO ADD THAT I'M REALLY
PROUD OF THE PROCESS AND THE
RESULTING CONSENSUS AND WANT TO
THANK YOUR STAFF FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT THEY'VE HELPED ON THE
BILL AND EVERYBODY ELSE THAT'S
BEEN HERE. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT TO
WEIGH IN IN SUPPORT WOULD BE
BETTER. HOST YOU, MISTER CHAIR
DYLAN ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, JORDAN
WALLACE, NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL, STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR ADAM WRIGLEY,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, WE REMOVED
ALL OPPOSITION. WE REALLY WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
STAKEHOLDERS FOR A PROCESS THAT
CAME TOGETHER AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MISTER CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, MARK ÁP, ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. THANK
YOU. MARK. OKAY ANYONE ELSE?
OPPOSITION CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL? NOPE. OKAY. LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. SEE IF
FOLKS HAVE QUESTIONS, THOUGHTS,
COMMENTS. MOVED BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ NØ SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. WE'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. YEAH, OKAY. WE GOT A
MOTION. WE'LL ENTERTAIN A VOTE.
LET'S LET'S CALL THE VOTE. SB
707. THE MOTION IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I
DALLY NÓ DALLY. NO. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HURTADO MENGIBAR.
NGUYEN. NO. NGUYEN. NO SKINNER.
SKINNER. I 3 TO 2. OKAY, THAT'S
3 TO 2. SO, WE NEED, CAROLINE OR
MELISSA TO COME ON DOWN. I KNOW
MELISSA IS OVER ON THE. SORRY.
CAROLINE IS OVER ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE FOR. TO BE UP FOR THE FIRST
PART OF THIS. OH. I'M SORRY.
YES. LET'S REOPEN THE ROLL FOR
THE FIRST BILL FOR SENATOR
SKINNER. GREAT. SB 1143, THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1 WITH THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATORS HURTADO. MENGIBAR
SKINNER. SKINNER I PORTABLE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
OKAY. SO LET'S LET'S OPEN THE
ROLL FOR BOTH. AND THEN WE WILL
WE WILL LIKELY ADJOURN BECAUSE
OUR COLLEAGUE, WHILE SHE HAS
EXPRESSED HER SUPPORT FOR BOTH
THE BILLS, IS BUSILY WORKING HER
BILLS ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE. SO
LET'S CALL THE ROLL FIRST ON
ITEM ONE, SB 707. THE MOTION IS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN THE CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATORS HURTADO HÌNH HURTADO I
MENGIBAR I WAIT FOR MY BILL. YOU
DON'T HEAR IT? YEAH. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. GOSH, THIS IS
THE KIND OF THIS IS THE SORT OF
FECKLESS FRIENDSHIP WE HAVE, I
SUPPOSE. YEAH. THERE YOU GO.
YEAH. OKAY. ALL RIGHT, NOW LET'S
DO THE SECOND ONE. SB 1143, THE
MOTION THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 1, WITH THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATORS HURTADO. YEAH, I
MENGIBAR 5 TO 1. GRAY. 5 TO 1.
SO YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT A SUNSHINE
PATRIOT. YEAH. OKAY. WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THE NEXT HEARING, WHICH WILL
BE WHEN? SATURDAY. NO IDEA.
WELL, HOPEFULLY A LOT BEFORE
MIDNIGHT ON SATURDAY. DO WE KNOW
WHEN IS IT? WHAT'S BETTS, WHAT'S
YOUR BEST GUESS? SCOTT LATE
AMENDMENTS. I'M JUST SAYING 6
P.M. ON SATURDAY. YEAH, I THINK
SO. SENATE-ROOM. OKAY. 6 P.M. ON
SATURDAY. WE'LL SEE YOU BACK.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GAVEL DOWN.